[Music]
new research is shedding light on how
children are affected by covid19 a study
in the journal jama pediatrics finds
more than 5 300 children and teenagers
in 22 states were hospitalized with the
disease between
may and november and some children are
facing serious complications among them
inflammation maria villarreal spoke with
one affected family in north texas where
coronavirus numbers
have been skyrocketing full of energy
and affection you'd never guess
eight-year-old van fuqua is bouncing
back from a disease
that left him struggling in a texas
hospital bed less than a month ago
my appetite is back what was it like
before
before it was like i was mostly asleep
like i slept like two naps a day yeah
two naps a day
his mother kate tested positive for
covet 19 back in november and the entire
family quarantined
as a precaution so we really kind of
thought we dodged the bullet
because i was the only one sick and
nobody else had any symptoms
but a month later van was hit with his
own symptoms
fatigue first then a fever of 104
degrees
a rash on his body strawberry tongue and
trouble walking
he tested negative for strep the flu and
two cova tests came back negative
leaving doctors scrambling to figure out
what was wrong he had some really scary
numbers on his labs like his heart was
in heart failure his kidneys looked bad
his liver looked bad
so they were really scrambling trying to
figure out you know
which one of these systems is the
culprit and
none of them were it was all an
inflammation reaction to the virus
the virus was covered and the diagnosis
was misc
short for multi-system inflammatory
syndrome a relatively
rare complication from covid in children
van is just one of more than 9 000 youth
covet cases
diagnosed in dallas county this past
december
one of america's most populated all the
trends are headed in the wrong direction
so i think it's going to be a pretty
dark
several weeks if not months as we move
through this pandemic
dr jeffrey khan heads the infectious
disease team at children's health
hospital in dallas
and says kids now make up 15 of dallas
county's
positive cases how did that happen the
virus is widespread in the community
right now
and it's easily transmissible
particularly in a household setting
so if you have somebody who's covered
positive regardless if they're
symptomatic or not
they enter a household the people in the
household are very high risk for getting
infected
more states across the country are
reporting increases in pediatric covert
hospitalizations
in utah a 5 000 percent increase
arizona 4000 and wisconsin south dakota
ohio and minnesota
are all reporting a more than one
thousand percent increase
dr khan says that means parents should
be on the lookout for signs of misc
the multi-system inflammatory syndrome
it can pop up
after kova 19 is long gone what is so
striking about this disease is that
for the most part these are otherwise
healthy children with no significant
medical history
who are coming in and are quite sick
many of these children are in heart
heart failure
uh require intensive care and we're
seeing more and more of this as
as the the pandemic evolves
an evolution being closely monitored by
health officials
around the country for cbs this morning
mira vial
dallas texas parents you know that
children with
misc may have a fever and various
symptoms including abdominal pain
vomiting diarrhea
neck pain rash bloodshot eyes or just
feeling extra tired important to point
out that the cdc says
not all children will have all of these
same symptoms so it's something to
monitor although rare